hello everyone welcome to a brand new
monthly podcast that does not have a
name we'll figure it out we hope that
you guys would be able to help us I'm
Alana PS is everyone else who's here
want to introduce yourselves
I'm Austin wintry and I'm the other a in
our nameless up and Adam which I'm gonna
start advocating for you're lobbying for
that so hard
I do like up and Adam I'm Troy Baker and
the T in this T in this cocktail and I'm
Mike and I've got terrible internet
connection
I'm unless you're close to your Rooter
I'm so close to my roots right now I can
see I'm very far from the rest of you
okay but this podcast this whole thing
is going to be us talking about all the
media that we've experienced in any
given month and I thought it was a
really cool idea because we all have
very different backgrounds but we're
from the same industry so I've been in
games media for 10 years Troy is a very
prolific voice actor Mike is a game
director and Austin is a compose oh so
we have very different fields within the
same industry and everyone's got a ton
of experience on this podcast so you
know let's prove that experience doesn't
matter at all and make total fools of
ourselves while talking about the things
we've checked out this month yes I think
it's also worth some context that the
the birthing of this was our glorious
New York comic-con panel celebrating
Mike biffle's and companies John wick
heck's unveiling and we discovered hey
we all don't hate each other when we're
talking about stuff so that's exciting
yeah yeah no no no it was it was don't
put the blame solely on yourself it was
the three of us going oh by the way
there's there's someone there's people
out here we're actually doing this in
front of other people yeah I hated it so
much I asked the three of you if you
would be willing to do a podcast so hate
yourself the torture was fun the whole
podcast was the three of you being like
no he's amazing no he's amazing and I
was like alright I guess we need a
format for the
so you guys could talk about how amazing
you offer a whole hour a month you you
were like you were like this is the this
is a group of guys we can absolutely
destroy over a series of podcasts where
they share that I can break this off oh
my god okay hold on
before we get too far down this road we
just got it everybody needs to
understand right we just started but I
can I can already see the the gleaning
of your eyes how excited you are to talk
about it because Austin oh you finished
this yeah that's my right as a dad
carving out time to sit down with
controller and hand in front of TV and
be able to complete a game that's been
very very hard I finally got to sit down
and take some time modern warfare is one
things I've been playing but after
everybody was just going crazy on the
Twitter's talking about fallen words
like okay okay okay
because I love like Force Unleashed was
one of my best Star Wars experiences so
I was super excited about this game I've
just started and I'll kick this off and
I'll let it go to you guys since you
have more experience playing it but
already it feels it was incredibly
intuitive I was bought in 100% I thought
it was it did a great job of tutorial
izing me world building and dropping me
into to their kind of own bespoke
timeline that they're doing but I I am I
wish that I wasn't talking to you three
and playing work I am just now he's on a
big train but basically the uncharted 2
sequence so he had you know we can call
it that right you're not wrong you're
not wrong you know but it's on a train
and he's like oh crap you know he's like
suspended he's even doing the
thirty minutes in it's worth putting an
asterisk that you said being a dad I
think it's like being a father aspiring
to be a good father because I think it
would have been very easy to just say
you you go away I have I have fallen
order to attend to for the next twenty
five hours
[ __ ] that kid I'd be fine the thing is
the thing with kids you've got to give
kids their freedom you've got to give
them space to grow on their own you
can't the thing is not so much like I
have to watch him he wants I love this
already because he already wants to be
involved so if if I'm I I've moved from
I still have a set up in like my studio
so I can play games in my studio but to
kind of be not so isolationist I have a
set up in the living room and so I have
a tendency to play in the living room so
if he's still awake he wants to be right
next to me watching and so it's just a
lot of like flashing colors and lights
and and things hitting a 18 month old
probably not too good for his
development I mean they're gonna have to
learn about lightsaber colors at one age
I don't see I don't see don't want red
green or blue yeah exactly I was over
since Knights of the Old Republic I
could never resist the yellow
lightsabers I always thought that was
purple if your mace windu purple would
be my go-to but I've been swapping
between in this game I guess Troy you
wouldn't be at the customization options
yet but I swapped the color depending on
what color my droid is and then what
color like poncho that's a lot of fully
changing it is but I gotta look cool so
there's an RPG element to this as well
it does have like full skill unlocks
like dogs all styles skill unlock so you
get it on fires like that that's a whole
part of this game yeah yeah I spend
you're not even at the point where the
whole Metroid II Dark Souls enos of it
all has kicked in right you're still
playing Star Wars uncharted which I'm
playing Star Wars and here's the problem
they're like in Red Dead I spent far too
long on my clothes and my appearance
like I look like Pat
Garet walking around and if anybody gets
that reference young guns - III was the
man in black so if there's any I'm
almost obsessive-compulsive when it
comes to RPG stuff like III will kind of
have intensity to stay away because I'll
spend far too long playing games that
have that element to it and and never
actually play the game it's like this
game is about these lights it's like
it's it's like a dialogue scene in a
Star Wars movie it knows why you came
okay but where it does get intense is I
finished one of the first world and it
said that I'd only done like 38% and I
thought that I had done everything
because you're getting you're unlocking
new abilities as you go to new planets
it's kind of Zelda style and yeah it is
very much road vania in a way the level
design doubles you back on stuff but
sometimes you'll still miss a ton of
stuff like I think I've missed tons of
force echoes which are just little
hidden things you can find so I have you
guys having trouble not doing it Troy
Mike and Alana have you guys finished am
I the only one has finished it or do you
guys also I haven't finished it I'm I'm
a ways into it but I've not completed it
because I the thing that to me its
strengths but also the thing that drives
me crazy as like an OCD kind of gamer in
the way that that you're talking about
like Troy with the RPG stuff I'm similar
but the thing that the thing that drives
me insane even though I I like this
about the game but it it's hitting me in
my weakness who just kind of wants to be
done with it and get back to like my
deadlines is is the fact that there will
be areas you'll come into an area that
the storyline takes you to but it's
gated by a force power you don't have
and it knows that five hours later or
ten hours later in the story is the only
time you're going to be able to actually
get to that secret so it's taunting you
to know that it's there because then
when you leave it says you know like you
said 30% completed because there's whole
[ __ ] that's designed for you to be
circling back to later and that drives
me crazy
because I have to do it I have no
avoidance of that I go back
it's tough I like that on I think it's
Balkan oh the Jedi planet don't like a
hub planet that you have I like it on
that because then every time you're
getting a new skill you can just return
to that really small planet and like
test it out on the environment there but
in some of the others I'm just choosing
to not go back I'm like I'm just not
gonna do this oh this is gonna be my
whole life
there are too many video games to play
but that's like a minor complaint that I
have like I really like this game I
think the first hour that Troy is
currently playing through is so strong
like when I played through that mother I
was like oh my god this is my game and
this is absolutely incredible but then
it is riddled with a bunch of technical
issues like the hitboxes is really bad
so I didn't I was I'm generally really
good at games like this and I was like
there is no way that I'm dying I don't
buy it
he's like you lying to me there is no
way this is my fault
so I recorded some of it and slowed it
down and there are really bad hip hop's
problems where something will hit you
but it was actually like two meters away
and then it'll just pull you into it's
basically its hit so it has a bunch of
things that I hope get patched that are
just over the course of the game I don't
know how long is it Austin well because
of my obsessive compulsive need to try
to max out that [ __ ] that I shouldn't
bother with I think for me it came in
around 25 hours but you could definitely
finish it faster than that yeah I feel
like I'll probably end up doing about 15
to 20 but there's just like a bunch of
small things that are over time wearing
down on me a bit like he just can't grab
a rope to save his life he really caught
I mean that gets so you a point where
grabbing ropes has gotten less difficult
a little yeah yes okay so you know I'm
talking about yeah yeah but yeah it's
it's one of those weird things with
where I got to that point and realized
oh so ropes were meant to be bad until
this point and it's that kind of there's
some weird stuff in there like that that
I think it definitely does suffer after
it's after it's left what we'll refer to
as the Troi zone if I go into this it
does it goes into a point where I'd say
for about two or three hours it's
actively trying to frustrate you so that
you feel powerful and empowered later
and you know that's definitely like a
game designer thing you know I've
definitely been guilty of
in my own games in the past and I can
kind of I can see how that decision
happened but it is it is one of those
ones it's kind of like when someone
recommends a TV show to you and you're
they're like oh we get so good in season
2 and I think that's kind of this game
is a little guilty of like Final Fantasy
13 or like you just got to put in 40
hours and I think that discussion with
death stranding in a minute because yeah
the onboarding is a thick because I'm
actually curious if Mike to hear more of
your perspectives specifically through
the lens of a designer because I felt
that I felt that as a player like being
being on boarded in to things or
tutorial eyes through skills force
powers world navigation kind of stuff
very deliberately one by one because
they were gonna be chaining them in cool
ways later but it felt it felt very kind
of it I don't even want I don't want to
say inorganic because I'm loving it but
or I loved it but it it still it felt
very sort of transparent like this is
what we're doing this is very gamey
there's no aspiration to kind of emergen
within the world of these things is that
my yeah I mean it's a newbie decision to
do that like in one how much you do I
think they narrative Lee explained it
nicely in this idea of he's kind of who
the character is who the protagonist is
well the backstory of that character is
again I'm going to avoid all that but
like I think they do have some nice in
universe justification of why he's
figuring it out as he goes along that's
fair enough but yeah it's a tricky one
we it was something we had in John wick
we had to figure out like how do we do a
skill tree like do we would would
players be okay with like John wick not
being able to reload his gun for the
first level like you know do you TVs in
because that's the thing with all things
gonna dribble to reload this gun so good
that's the thing I think it's been I
don't think players necessarily picked
up on this but the reason skill trees
and RPG light mechanics have kind of
caught on so much in triple-a at least
is it's a really good way of breaking up
your tutorial you can kind of meter out
stuff if you were playing spider-man and
you had
all of the abilities in spider-man in
the first level it's overwhelming how
long how enough do you kind of teach a
player that so it's it's kind of it's
not so much actually
I always think they didn't prototype
that game prototype it's so odd they
stopped you with everything from the
start and then they space it out really
slowly throughout the game and I feel
like they had that problem but had to be
like it's not cool enough from the
get-go we have to make its way cool
Force Unleashed was the same way you
start off as playing as Vader and you're
like this is where I'm altima League
owing to go and then they strip you away
from all of that I love that feeling
because you start off with this this
sense of God loss yeah what yeah you
start off godlike you're like I have
every freaking ability and once you've
tasted that even if you just back it off
40% you feel so incredibly challenged so
them there's a greater sense of
satisfaction kind of piggybacking off of
what Austin said Mike do you it really
for everybody is it possible for you to
just play a game without like Mike you
as a designer writer designer but the
programmers would disagree with you but
I have released games I kind of do
things like whether or not I'm a
programmer is a different question but
but all of us have our kind of our
matrix that we can kind of look at games
so when you sit down and you play a game
like fallen order are you able to just
I'm gonna experience this thing at face
value the way that it was intended can
you just look at this as impartially
as the average consumer or you kind of
are you beyond that starting with Mike
if it's good I forget is the honest
answer
I was playing fallen order for I'd say
fall in order for the first five or six
hours I was playing I was like oh this
is a this is a nice mid budget uncharted
clone oh no it's actually an interesting
like Dark Souls mainstream if occation
kind of process for about six hours I
was playing it very kind of academically
and interested and then it got good and
I stopped paying attention I just saw
having fun that's generally it for me as
I'll I'll play things in an analytic
go away until they're good enough but I
forget that I've got this is a job
that's my answer I mean I will always
criticize everything that I play out of
habit I do it to movies as well I can't
see something and not criticize it but I
find that fun so it doesn't detract for
anything from me but then I also always
like what is this going to impact the
industry how is this going to impact
future games so yes I always think about
stuff that way but I like that so much
that it almost makes the experience
better rather than was a vast
immobilizer that Ilana because I feel
like you've specifically relative to the
three of us you've you've like
professionalized you know analysis and
and and all the things that we're
talking about you've you've you've made
that a core part of your your career and
so it seems like it puts you in an
impossible position I mean correct me if
I'm wrong in other words if that to tune
out and just play like any other player
wouldn't that essentially be you like
wouldn't it be the sort of lost work you
know in a in some sense like you you've
oh yeah now you're now you're kind of
you'd have to go back and play it again
essentially and kind of do anything
again yeah I think I mean my biggest
complaint about like reviewing games
full-time or whatever you want to call
it is probably that I now I took a hobby
that I had since I was like four years
old and I now feel like I have to do it
constantly I won't watch TV or movies
because I'm like I should be playing
video games because I need to have
played all the video games because I
need to understand all of the video
games and so it's giving me this
constant sense of like needing to work
it's probably a feedback thing to like
what you're talking about is that I
constantly have to criticize stuff and
then that feels good because I feel like
I'm doing my job so that I'm obsessed
with doing it but I like it people ask
all the time if I ever get burnt out and
I'm like if I did I'd probably leave the
industry like I'm not even close to
being burnt out on video games at this
point so I'm good are you reviewing this
podcast right now and Austin's face
keeps being brought out by the autoblow
it's a real problem forever and why why
were the developers so lazy that they
made Austin's background boards thanks
by the way you know that someone's gonna
be like best podcast ever Screen Rant
said that's the thing I just do
occasionally like it's not a profession
but if I go to a club and I hear a bad
DJ big drives be not so be like he
didn't even mix that he actually just
press play and I can always tell you
have that with music and things like if
that bad does completely ruin it for you
or how much attention do you pay to a
school it's the same it's honestly the
same answers Mike I if when things are
great you reach some point where you
just are in it and you're no longer like
analyzing it and then if it's really
really great the the joy is going back
and actually kind of digging in deeper
and understanding it more and realizing
like holy [ __ ] there's actually all a
whole goldmine of crap here I missed I
you know I went into this game to fall
in order I mean very aware of the
backstory on it's music because it's
written by two composer friends of mine
it was an interesting story because
Gordy hab has been doing he's become
kind of EA's chosen one for all Star
Wars related music he was doing
Battlefront 1 & 2 and he had worked on
the Old Republic and you know for Lucas
arts and had been around and done lots
of this and had really perfected the the
the the sort of what I think it was the
LA Times or somebody referred to it as
John Williams b-sides like managing to
nail that aesthetic perfectly so that it
sounds like it's somehow music that John
Williams had written that we just had
never heard before and so he was he was
kind of the go-to guy on that for years
leading up to this but then also in
tandem with that respawn has been
working through the titanfall series
with a guy named Stephen Barton pretty
loyally for the last number of years and
so it was like well we also need like 8
plus hours of score so we're just gonna
kind of throw it at both of you guys and
so they went into it having to kind of
you know match this kind of
triangulation of their own sort of input
in the fact that they're individually
quite different composers from each
other but it also has to be super
authentically Star Wars like that was
the thing it wasn't in contrast to
Mandalorian which is like let's do
something wildly different from the
traditional John Williams thing let's do
something that's super traditional to
the point of literally all done Abbey
Road London Symphony no-expense-spared
full-on and and so I went in knowing all
that had been going on for a while and
so I went in like very ready to consume
the score and to the point that it was
like every for the first few hours I was
kind of that's kind of my primary
motivator is I was like I'm curious how
they're gonna handle this and that and
this and and seeing it and then yeah at
some point I was just playing it and
like sitting there going you know god
damn stormtroopers shouldn't be able to
kill me that easily and I'm like totally
forgotten all about the score with the
[ __ ] goats I hate [ __ ] the Rams
are little Rams goddamn anything in that
game I'm good but as soon as I see one
of those I start sweating I'm like oh I
feel like you guys are [ __ ] with you
right now and then the clowns come in
it's just chaos I don't you want to ask
Austin I wanna ask Austin a music
question how do you feel I loved I
genuinely can't stop thinking about how
clever it is the licensed track there's
like a Mongolian metal band who did it's
the music the song I think they are
literally Mongolian they said the song
of the star and then it's in a fight
later on yeah I just think that's so
clever like hiring basically a band that
fits into the Star Wars universe because
most your audience don't speak their
language and sounds just perfect well
funny enough so I that was really first
question I had after playing the game I
I called up Gordy and I said what's with
that song at the beginning I said was
that was that licensed or was that or
was that raid he said that that band
wrote that for the game
and it's not even licensed okay yeah I I
feel like in terms of feeling Star Wars
II I feel like the whole game nails that
and that maybe is a weird thing to say
but like so many aspects of it that oh
well I actually did hear that it was
originally a lot more Dark Souls II and
they scaled it back I'm not sure why
that decision was made but it was
probably that it's it's still EA I mean
they give respawn a lot of creative
freedom and respawn this generation of
made incredible games like apex legends
and titanfall two of both amazing but I
would guess it was like Dark Souls is
still not quite mass audience
they sell exactly well but I can see EA
being like no that's too difficult so
maybe scale it back and I feel like
there's a lot of those elements in the
game but when it comes to the core of it
it still feels so Star Wars II all of
the characters the shipmates that you
have sorry feel very so cozy the planets
do the cutscenes do like I feel like
they just nailed that vibe that's gotta
be really difficult it's inspiring I
wonder with the Dark Souls thing if that
was also I don't have any insider
knowledge but I wonder if I wonder if
part that was actually respawn Cummings
like one of the things I really respect
respawn for is their game feel and their
design in there they clearly do a lot of
really smart thinking about the player
experience and around the design of of
interactions in general and I really
yeah I've definitely played it and felt
like there was stuff that was being done
to streamline and ease that game not in
a kind of making games easy kind of
sense but just in terms of making it
feel good other than the kind of
technical issues you mentioned Alana I
think but give it a couple of months and
I feel like this game is going to be
amazing
yeah I think I think aesthetically what
intrigues me about it is that it is this
kind of it exists in this middle space
between the prequel and the original
trilogy and I think they've done he
reminded me a lot of galaxies edge
they've done such a good job of kind of
combining everyone's Star Wars like it
feels like a really interesting mashup
in kind of a lot of the architecture is
this kind of old a lot of the
architecture is like pure kind of Star
Wars retro and then you have these kind
of temple spaces that vary
kind of prequel trilogy and it kind of
it feels like it's it's nailing kind of
two very different aesthetics and
bringing them together which is really
clever
really nice yeah I actually I think I
think it even it even goes farther than
that because that first planet the kind
of hub planet he feels very much like
Knights of the Old Republic to me and oh
let's try that like which you know
that's that game takes place like like
2,000 years before the movies are sort
of like that you know it's something
something wildly outside of the north of
mainstream Canada this stuff and I love
the way like the fact that the very
beginning of this is all the like clone
trooper and clone Star Destroyer
military stuff that Salvage planet I I
think I have a soft spot for those
little intermediary places within the
story between the big events and like
exploring the fringes of that it's the
same it's the same with Mandalorian like
let's let's look at kind of the piles of
rubble around these big explosions that
our movies are based around and to me
that yeah that was an amazing choice
from them of where to pick this where
they could tell their own story but yet
it it like the more kind of the deeper
nerd you are in Star Wars kind of
fictional or the more the game offers
you which is pretty there's even a yeah
ttle name-drop like the one the
background female Yoda on the Jedi
Council infantile and they make some
comment in one of the like you know
extra dialogues like are you talking
about Yoda no I'm talking about yea tall
and I was like oh man this was made by
my kind of people that also feels really
intentionally related to Mandalorian no
one's ever mentioned you at all in the
past decade not one time well now you're
talking about it I get that it does feel
really cohesive right now but it is also
crazy that I'm more excited about every
episode of Mandalorian and more excited
about playing Jedi fallen order than I
am about the fact that there's a [ __ ]
Star Wars maybe just about to come out I
keep forgetting right I'm in the same
bow like suddenly I'm a Star Wars fan
and it's weird yeah well holy because of
those two things being awesome Mike were
you not like like coming into this were
you not a big Star Wars nerd I was a
Star Wars fan in the same way as I like
like other movies like they are just a
movie franchise like I've seen every
Star Wars so in other words no you're
not a Star Wars fan
no no just like pop culture I just like
movies like it they were just films like
that's the thing is and that's such a
weird thing to say about Star Wars but
yeah they were there were fun films I
you know when I saw them in the cinema
and had a nice time but no the yeah it's
exactly as Alana said like Mandalorian
and falling all this suddenly their Star
Wars that I'm excited by and interested
in that world and what's nice is because
Star Wars is just so all-encompassing
and permeates everything I know the
backstory
I know the world I know enough just
through osmosis that that's you know
without watching everything you don't
need to watch every movie religiously
because pop culture is just gonna keep
regurgitating everything anyway so ya
know it's there there is an element
though now that we're so far removed
first from the first three movies but
we're also even removed from the
prequels and there are people that are
coming in that the Mandalorian or this
game hmm could be their first foray into
this so III think that for those of us
that grew up with this and some of us
who literally grew up with all of it my
first movie I think was was seeing this
in the theater I don't remember it cuz I
would've been a year old but I I've been
with this from the very inception of it
and washes it's like you said permeated
throughout our culture and it is at the
very foundation of pop culture but there
are people who were not even born when
the prequels came out that are now this
is they're they're now experiencing this
and it's interesting to see the
disparity between someone who is in
their 30s or 40s watching Star Wars
going I can't believe this thing is
finally ending and someone else going
well they just started doing these
movies I understand there's movies other
70s like what Saga it's like this is the
third we have we have prequels all the
time
and like this is the same culture that
would have experienced Harry Potter and
like all 30 movies of those with Lord of
the Rings you know sort of there were
these you know 12 movie franchises so to
a lot of people this is not that big of
a deal but there wasn't this before in
our culture we didn't have don't lead
only serialized movies that we had were
Bond films like they and they just kept
cranking those and there were kind of
some the Rocky movies they were Rambo's
but we didn't really have a lot of
sequels and in franchises alien I guess
nobody even then all of those are after
Rocky is 76 I think and or 78 maybe 70
77 the new hope is 77 also yes for sure
79 and also the Bond films are more like
an anthology series each film is kind of
screwed off with vague connective tissue
to the other films so I agree these were
an anomaly plus on top of that one of my
favorite little trivia things for Star
Wars God finds that that's also like
around the same year too but like but
like what's brilliant about this is
George Lucas and Spielberg completely
tricked all of us because about 20 years
before Star Wars it was only serialized
movies like the the idea they they
brought this back but like I was
listening to a listen weird things I was
into a history of the Sherlock Holmes
franchise and like by the sixties it was
like Sherlock Holmes versus the Nazis
because they run out of Sherlock Holmes
to make movies like the same thing right
all of these all of this stuff is
historically there what Lucas and
Spielberg did with Indiana Jones and
Star Wars was they yeah reinvented this
beautifully and brought back a
serialized stuff it's it's interesting
that that serialized structure seems to
be something that has generational gaps
right because now we're in the Marvel
Universe right there's this kind of
there's these kind of these waves of it
happening and that's that's interesting
that we kind of forget
about serialized movies then they come
back then they go again and the thing
that's exactly though is it's almost
like kiss doing a farewell tour right
like they're on their third farewell
tour maybe fifth and in some ways you
can kind of compare kiss with Star Trek
first or with Star Wars because yeah
well how do ya we [ __ ] rabbit
hopefully went to but here is this band
that you're not gonna look at kiss and
go wow those are great musicians right
but what they did for music is they they
assured in this element they picked up
where where David Bowie left off and
they took glam and brought it into metal
and they spawned this entire genre of
this big theatrical us you know Alice
Cooper and and and kiss created this
whole theater of music and brought it
back to two or it was calling back to to
what music used to be with opera and now
here it is presented in this incredible
new pop culture framework but Star Wars
has been kind of the same thing if you
want to break down from a this is not
Fellini you're not gonna look at this
and go look at this cinematography look
at that it's just the scope and the
epicness of what they did and how much
the the single boom that is that has
continued to have a ripple effect
throughout culture both video games TV
film literature it just continues to
grow and there's no stopping it now
especially but this is the thing it
you're like the saga will end no it
won't because there's three shows on TV
they're gonna constantly do this have we
lost the feeling of what it means for
something to end and for it to finally
be like we're putting a period on the
end of this we're closing the book
because Marvel's doing the same thing
it's like endgame kind of we're gonna
continue to do like all of these
different endgame until next month when
spider-man comes out and then I love how
the opening scene of spider-man makes
super light of like this this world
altering event that would have
traumatized
to everyone for all of history and
they're like I was I mean we've kind of
homogenized what it means to end
something because there's it's just kind
of everything as perpetual so I don't I
don't know how people feel about like
you said you're more excited about the
mandalorian you're more excited about
this game than you are the lie I
regardless when I saw the trailer for
the first time for rise of Skywalker I
stills like oh like there's some really
big scenes in there that the hug to Leia
got me even like Finn's like big like
whoa I there's something that it has the
ability to still rally me as a kid from
the 70s and 80s that it hits to my very
very soul but that's me growing up I
don't know if there are people out there
now they can have the same appreciation
for this because they haven't had for
decades of this I mean I don't feel like
I grew up with Star Wars but I think
knowing the significance on its impact
on pop culture and on the film industry
has made me appreciate it a whole lot I
mean I watched the movies when I was a
kid but then didn't for a really long
time again until maybe five years ago
but I I still like I see a star destroy
come out of the ocean in that trailer
and I'm like damn that's cool right but
it's for that for the most part I don't
feel like I did grow up before that I'm
not four decades old
so definitely didn't have that
experience but I think Star Wars is like
you know the conversation people having
right now is with soullow coming out as
it lost magic because it is being
serialized is it less special now does
that take away from Star Wars
Skywalker's tickets sales are currently
less than any of the new movies I don't
know what any of it means all I know is
I love my work which is like I don't
know what the impact on the staying
power of Star Wars is going forward I
feel like it's probably such a rich
universe with so much law that it's like
there's so many things to pull from is
ultimately the thing and no matter what
my thing is I fully appreciate what
George Lucas did for the film industry
like the changed a lot of stuff through
this space fantasy vessel with I mean
IOM and everything they did you just
changed so exactly normally
technologically I mean the Star Wars the
highest
the highest-grossing sci-fi of all time
prior to Star Wars was 2001 which was
almost a decade earlier and it made like
15 million dollars or something in the
box office and Star Wars in 1977 dollars
made like three hundred million dollars
domestically yeah anyway the song was
came out it was the highest-grossing
film of all time yeah I have no idea but
snots it's still it's still very near
the top when you adjust for inflation
because it's just it was like this thing
where every theater you know multiplex
has didn't exist like they do now so it
would be the theater with the one screen
and they just showed it for like a year
because it just kept selling out over
and over and over it's crazy but I say
as someone who is a pretty lifelong like
die-hard Star Wars nerd who you know
I've been like mildly heartbroken over
the sequel trilogy because to me it felt
like it didn't it didn't it just took it
in a direction that felt so far it felt
Larry lowest-common-denominator felt so
off of the of the of what makes Star
Wars Star Wars and I hate to sound like
that fan no I agree I totally agree like
I could not couldn't help but make a
stocky comment about the most recent
trailer where they're like they fly now
they fly now they fly now like you have
to say that three times it has to be and
that's not what Star Wars used to be
that's like them trying to be very
Marvel and formulaic and I think that's
probably started part of where the
fatigue has come off to get into like
Scorsese's comments they are formulaic
they follow the same beats and have the
same viewer and I feel the same way but
still you pull a Star Destroyer out of
some water I'm very excited well so
that's where for me like the the the
that's where this like what Troi a
second saying it's they're gonna go
about there are kids especially who
maybe their first entry point right now
into Star Wars is something like the
Mandalorian or fallen order and as
someone who has read a lot of the Star
Wars you know expanded universe books
and had a you know I played every game
that's been released and seen all the
movies a million times and had every
edition every version of like when they
would do a new trilogy box set you know
the laserdisc the laserdisc remastered
the blahblah as the guy
that obsessively had all those things
the idea that someone is experiencing
Star Wars for the first time via either
fallen order or Mandalorian is amazing
to me because it's like they're getting
the real [ __ ] in my mind when I see if
it would be like if your favorite movie
ever was Bullitt and you're like cool
fast car movies are being exposed by
Fast and the Furious did everybody see
Mike's face by the way is your favorite
movie ever and Fast and the Furious is
like someone's introduction to car
movies they're probably not going to end
up at bullet but that's where it's like
if Mandalorian is your entry into Star
Wars
you'll probably watch the originals and
be like [ __ ] this is amazing okay but
building off of that if you were to go
and watch if you're if you're first like
okay let's watch car chase movies right
and you started off with fast and
furious but you don't understand that
fast and furious is built off of bullet
and French Connection and Ronin and all
of these classic like you have to see
these seminal cinematic car chases and
you go backwards it's like someone is
like hey you should try cocaine and then
like after doing all of the cocaine just
like maybe you should smoke a cigarette
you're like that means nothing to me
what no III think that someone is like
it's too much it's um it's there's too
much sugar in in in in the sweets that
we have now as opposed to just we
overload stuff with with flavor and I
think that's the I went in and watched
this
was the second one final coal whatever
recalling its sequel called what was it
that the one that just came out last
last Jedi thank you thank you there's
too many titles sorry I went in after
the first one was like I'm just gonna
let this wash over me I'm gonna done
gonna take whatever they give me flying
Leila or Leia absolutely great why not
it didn't bother me and I loved the
moment with Luke I thought that was a
great send-off to one of the best
characters out of their franchise I was
totally fine with everything and
everything came out like it didn't do
what I wanted it to do and I think that
was the fear that it was made in was it
just didn't trust itself it didn't it
felt like oh we have to overcompensate
now for the prequels we have to wrap
this thing up and we have to make sure
that everybody thinks this is the
greatest thing ever oh [ __ ] look what
Marvel's doing Oh God
and it was just piling on stuff when you
look back to the first three movies and
they go we don't know man we're just
some little like you said space fantasy
that's being shot in the middle of
Tunisia that that is introducing a whole
new language and in type of characters
and building a world and had nothing to
do with spectacle and and having to wrap
up everything it's the same problem that
Game of Thrones had it's like how do you
how in the world do you put a button in
a bow on what literally changed the face
of television a series that changed the
face of television and I think that they
just didn't trust themselves and that
happens with games as well when when
games are designed and developed to Mike
you know this when they don't trust when
that's the critical element they can
have the best design which they won't if
they don't trust what they have the best
music which they won't if they don't
trust best performances someone like
Alana is gonna find it and cut it to
ribbons because you feel the lack of
trust in it I feel personally attacked
sorry didn't like quarantine circular
okay Troy subsurface circular by the way
to me that that was something that
trusted itself because it didn't it
wasn't trying to do anything it was just
like what happens if I do this how do
you feel about this yes we're here to
make you blush
I think that Mike sari going along
because there's a slight delay we talk
over each other I think one of the
issues with the lost Jedi is the amount
of criticism the force awakens' got for
being too similar to a new hook so they
were like let's make it completely
different and my biggest issue with that
movie is that it's bad improv I feel
like what the last Jedi does that I
really don't like is just completely
ignores everything the film before set
up in a way that you're like it just
doesn't do any yes and it's no but all
of them so now I'm at this point where
I'm not super excited about a new Star
Wars movie because I feel like I don't
have a lot of stakes I feel like I don't
really
there hasn't been something built up
throughout the course of two films it
just there was one film and then the
other film presented me with a bunch of
completely different stuff and now I'm
like I don't know what you want me to
care about but I still like the space
battles but that's part of why form and
order I really wanted to make the point
of how Star Wars II it feels and
obviously this is totally an opinion
what you take from Star Wars is one of
the coolest things about is it lets you
take whatever you want
but I feel like I feel like fallen order
is very Star Wars II and has the essence
of what I like about Star Wars whereas I
felt like the new trilogy of films has
not done that and then Mandalorian
something different entirely it feels
Star Wars II and that there are a lot of
weird aliens but it's also basically a
Western yo the Sergio Leone aspect is my
take sorry you could take Troy's angle
out you can like that as a way of
thinking about these things the the idea
of stuff that's not trying to be
something else that's trying to has
faith in an idea because I think fallen
order is very much trying to do
something brave and interesting with the
IP I think the Mandalorian is just kind
of unapologetically like a 90s western
TV show that's why I love about
Mandalorian is I think there's been a
lot of conversation about how cinematic
it is I love how TV is yeah Mandalorian
just feels like the stuff I loved as a
kid watching on TV like it feels it's
not embarrassed to be a TV show
Mandalorian it feels it's paced it feels
like dr. Quinn Medicine Woman and I love
it how keeps that baby though
that's well we have spent a lot of time
just now talking about Star Wars we
probably could have done this whole
thing I don't know I feel like this this
first episode is 100% there look there's
there's forty years and and as Austan
put it just a litany of source material
it was a Kathleen Kennedy that made a
thing is we're not sure what's gonna
happen with Star Wars movies because
there's just there's no more source
material I'm like what are you talking
there is there is a the most source
material I said there's more source but
Center for Star Wars and there is the
Bible anymore but I feel like the
talking about this specifically it
deserves its its own little it's a
little one-shot it's a little episode
god damnit wintry going I know I know I
know
I want to springboard off a thing you
were talking about a minute ago Troy
when you were saying about things not
trusting themselves cuz that that's huge
for me I would so much rather watch a
show or a movie or play a game or II or
listen to an album that has that fails
utterly in its complete conviction in
itself yes then something that's all
cynically like this is what people love
and it got me like well first off we
never heard from you if you're able to
play things without analyzing
performance or or the caliber of the I
do want to hear that cow yeah I want to
hear your take on that but that's not
what I was going to say so I'm putting
I'm keeping my browser tab you only get
one question Austin no no that same
thing I
if something is bad especially from a
performance standpoint it's gonna stand
out to me and it's gonna I'm not going
to think as as there's not there's less
happening under the hood with a
performance right it's in your face
that's what's being presented to you
versus Mike's able to look at it and the
design and go oh because they were you
know they were Devin this and unreal I
know what their limitations were and so
I can see what they're doing and there's
literally a matrix that someone who has
experience coding programming designing
is able to see that the average consumer
is not if it's a bad performance you
don't go well I don't know what what's
happening you're like you see it it's
face value
we had performances where you it was
like a direction that that the that that
was leaning out of the strengths of the
actor I mean doesn't it happen you will
never know I will never know you as a
viewer will never know if the reason why
you saw a bad performance was because of
the director because of the actor
there's a body of work that stands
behind some actors you're like whoa
they're normally really really good but
this director must have like or there's
so much that can be done in editing
there's so much that you put the wrong
camera angle on somebody and it
completely changes the story so yeah why
the hell do you think they picked Hayden
Christensen for Anika
there is something in have you ever well
you laugh but I mean have you ever seen
Hayden in person no okay he doesn't come
round anymore
people can hate this but I've been
around Hayden a few times and I don't I
don't know him we're not friends I've
just been around him a few times and if
I were casting that movie and Hayden
Christensen walked in i 100% would cast
him he does this thing when he smiles
you look at him here like he's so meek
in me he's impressive his stature like
he and I are eye-to-eye is a very tall
guy but when you when you look at him
any smiles there is this you see someone
smiling but on the back half he has this
not put on broodiness it's like a James
Dean look where you like you can smile
but there's pain in those eyes and I
think that George Lucas looked at that
and said I need to see this character in
transition because we go super
saccharine sweet with little Annie and I
need to see how this person becomes
Darth Vader and I can 100% see and if
you've seen subsequent stuff with with
Hayden Christensen he's a good actor
he's a really really good actor and I
see his smile turn to like evil like
that so there's I get why he was cast I
think that Hayden Christensen was
the hood ornament of a of a train that
was just destined to fail this is
terrible but like you watched Natalie
Portman and you're like no she put in
the work she does she always dies though
she does even then though I think it's I
think it's probably hands-down the
weakest I've ever seen Natalie Portman
too which is why I think it it points to
the direction more than the performer
which is that's why I asked and that's
it's also armchair directing like as if
I could do it obviously not at all I
think that purportedly as I understand
it you're not George Lucas as a film
director right Martin Scorsese is a
director in the sense that he will get
into characters and he really loves to
work with his actors George Lucas has no
heart he didn't and that's he is great
at story building he's great at giving
you character archetypes and he's great
at cinematically setting this up but
Steven Spielberg was always the one that
was like working with the actors and
really kind of digging in there so
that's why the two of them worked so
well together but George Lucas isn't
gonna look I remember them telling
stories about him on set and he was just
like don't ask me about what your
motivation was don't ask me about what
what your intention is I need you to
stand there and move to there because
I'm gonna have you can't see it right
now but there's this huge robot you know
he's just he's setting up a shot as
opposed to really building a scene and I
think when you have someone like Hayden
where you're not working I've worked
with actors on a mocap stage where you
walk into this white room this white
padded room and you're wearing this
stupid suit and a helmet on your head
and a camera right here and you're like
okay know what you can't see right now
is you're standing in the middle of this
blank and you're facing off with blank
and people are like I don't I don't know
what to do because I'm used to these
these trappings and these accoutrements
to making a movie or a TV show that I
have I'm completely robbed of right now
and if you don't have a director that's
making that
actor feels safe then that actor is
coming from a place of fear as opposed
to coming from a place of faith and and
your performance will always fall flat
and the audience will smell it somehow
they won't connect with that character
they won't connect with that scene or
most people will write off the movie as
like ad just wasn't good and they won't
be able to tell you why it's funny
because there are these noteworthy
exceptions like Alec Guinness in the
original trilogy and Liam Neeson in the
Phantom Menace where they just they just
do their thing and it's like they just
kind of act circles around everybody
else sure and it's like I guess they're
fine there are there are always actors
who are more kind of I guess workman
like definitely like you know my
experience directing actors you have
actors who really want you to walk them
through every single choice and you've
got to be available to them for that and
then you also have actors who show up
and want to read their lines and they're
fine and and with you know frankly those
actors are often like like and Alec in
this like of a callable where you can
just let them roll and I've worked with
both kinds of actors and it's the
director's role to kind of give it act
to what they need that's it yes in some
in some cases like obviously a director
can give an actor what they need and I
don't think George Lucas star was it
still his baby but he didn't care that
much about those movies narrative Lee he
was just like I just want to test out
this tech I want to make the first ever
digital shot like that was what his goal
was and he again he changed the industry
by doing that I get what that means that
people got bad scripts and bad
performances and Carrie Fisher wasn't
better help so they were kind it's
really limited by that right we're all
limited by our passions we're all
limited by what we actually care about
and that's I think every creative
process yeah what do you say what was
the other question that you had left in
you that I it's I was thinking of it
beforehand that I was teasing you guys
about I was I was hinting at a kind of
slightly provocative question that
occurred to me while I was sitting in
the airport in Mobile Alabama last night
which is the weirdest sentence I've ever
heard you say
in a long lineage of weird sentences
[Music]
such as your pad thai is getting cold oh
is it oh of course
oh god we're going to reorder that [ __ ]
the I was thinking to myself and and you
sent it up perfectly when we were
talking about kind of authenticity
versus not in these games and these
shows how frayed are they to be
themselves regardless of what they're
being measured against and blah blah
blah and cuz last night unrelated
without knowing you were gonna bring
that up but kind of perfectly attuned to
that I was asking I was curious to ask
you guys within your particular
professions what do you think
constitutes the biggest or the riskiest
choice the biggest risk I was gonna say
the riskiest choice that you can make do
you understand what I'm at am i clear in
my question because I think it's there's
a lot of ways to do what we all
individually do very safely which can
very quickly be a very cynical thing
like ah if I just do this I'm not gonna
make waves and probably it'll work out
well and it might find an audience there
level what's the hard opposite of that
what's the riskiest thing that you think
you can do my answers are all really
uninteresting I think but it's I
remember I was one of the first people
to play Mass Effect Andromeda and
everyone was very excited about it and I
walked out of the room off to having
played for three hours and had this
moment where I was like [ __ ] I have to
be the one to tell everyone that this
game is intersex yeah but it's crushing
because hey it sucks the developers but
mostly I was like I'm going to get
destroyed because they aren't going to
believe me because this is Mass Effect
and I was like [ __ ] like I have to write
about how bad this looks
how buggy it is how bro we I think the
dialogue is and it's just like this
crushing feeling with the easy route
would be like Mass Effect Andromeda is
amazing and you're all gonna love it cuz
that's the bias that people generally
want to read from that kind of thing but
I couldn't do it had a really similar
thing with no man sky and I still have
all the comments saved where they were
like stupid [ __ ] fire her and I'm like
well I caught damn apologies for that
and obviously the other one is not
pissing off publishers but yeah I feel
like with journalism it's just being
honest is unfortunately sometimes the
Rickey did the riskiest puff but if you
don't do it you're not really a
journalist but there's been validation
for that I would think like it's like
you'd like no man's sky you mentioned
specifically like like masoom have you
ever have you ever failed that - have
you ever have you ever thought oh [ __ ]
this is I don't feel right being
completely transparent or completely
open and then and then it you know it's
been completely honest but I have also
sometimes like I think I've I've changed
my mind about something later
I gave super hot just the original game
a 7.5 and I'm like that was such a
mistake that's I think the only review
school that I was like that was way too
low I don't know what I was doing and my
logic was that the game doesn't evolve
throughout I think it's five hours when
it wasn't in VR and it's also clearly
designed for vo so it's a little bit
different when you're playing it was
just on PC at the time I was like it
doesn't actually add anything new it's
just the same thing with slightly more
enemies in it doesn't evolve enough it
was like does that really matter when
the game is really fun but I've never
I've never not been honest in something
that would be a nightmare this this is a
problem that I think we have pervasively
throughout the industry where as we head
into awards season for four games
especially there's no criterium and
people forget that it's subjective this
is my opinion it's my take on it there's
no on the on the true dur scale of
whatever you can't quantify your your
opinion something that you said Ilana I
read a quote that I really loved I'm
speaking about being a journalist which
is very relevant to our culture right
now the quote says if someone says it's
raining and another person says it's dry
it's not your job to quote them both
your job is to look out the [ __ ]
window and find out which is true and I
think that right now you having your
opinion this and go here is most people
can
say here's why and give you a critical
analysis critical analysis of why they
think it's a 7.5 or why Andromeda is bad
there's like just didn't like it and it
didn't satisfy something within me as
opposed to here is a standard for
cinematography here is a standard for
dialogue here's a standard for design
here's a standard for this you being
able look at and go it really never
iterated upon itself it's just kind of
through different enemies at you same
enemies saving them whereas crystal boys
yeah fun mechanic that never changes
they just kind of go well now you're
using shuriken now you're using a bottle
now you're using guns I I think that
that's
a valid point but it's I hate awards
because they don't i'm dovetailing off
of your question austin but don't worry
I'm still gonna hold you accountable and
all of us have at some point been in
contention for some award and it doesn't
mic I think it impacts you the most
because if I mean exists that's why this
is all an intervention actually yeah if
I don't get an award
I just I'm like ah I'm still gonna go
get drunk at the BAFTA Party right if
you don't if the three of us don't get
to work but if Bissel games doesn't get
to put game of the year there are
bonuses that are not triggered there's a
there's an opportunity for re marketing
and repackaging that game that that
allows for more revenue to be brought in
or probably more likely there's a chance
for that game to the sequel to not be
made and you have to start all over from
an IP so I understand four and now we've
got golden joysticks we've got Baptist
we've got Game Awards we've got all of
these different awards that people can
now say game of the year but we don't
have the standard here is the boom this
is the definitive game of the year and
now all the game awards have gone to
most anticipated game that to me skews
the voting for what the actual true game
of the year is that people's jobs are
kind of depending on yeah I mean it's a
shame it's a shame I don't think that's
a fair amount of pressure to put on the
journalistic establishment to be honest
right like it's it's a really to
something obviously as a game developer
who releases games relatively regularly
I get to encounter you know I've got
I've got friends who hate specific games
I've made you know and that's fine you
know and it's not a thing I think I
think what's also really interesting is
if you make
something I'm training of the word
consistent or well thought if you make
something that's just terrible
you'll read 20 reviews that all pick on
you know have different problems where
they're you know this is terrible this
is terrible this is terrible if you make
something that's consistent and quote
unquote competently made you'll get the
same review 20 times and you'll just get
to see the subjective difference in how
much people care about certain things
it's really that's kind of interesting
you almost do get to an objective truth
the the problem is the review score or
the the assumption that you know there's
any kind of metric to how good something
is I think reviews are fantastic and
they're useful and both for both the
audience and for the people who make
games but it is is [ __ ] that
anyone's basing any kind of payment or
or or future plans on any of this stuff
awards are nonsense
the trick with non well with awards is
to know they're nonsense when you're
winning them as well yes that's the
thing I think people travel with it's
very easy to kind of get get very
excited when you make something that is
a bit of a darling that yeah so yeah it
doesn't change it's fair I don't think
it's fair for journalists to have to
even think about any of this stuff I
think it's it sucks that that situation
has been produced by often by people who
don't have taste and rely on outsourcing
it to other people but it's also I do
want to say I think yeah I don't like
review schools and I feel like virtually
every other games journalist I know
doesn't like review scores but the
audience likes them so much they'll
complain about them but they like there
are so much evidence that they will look
at a review score and ignore everything
else that to get rid of them would hurt
outlets more than help them but as well
where the critics that are often very
good a lot of the very good critics are
the ones who've been able to get the
review score like no longer to be part
of the process so I'll often find that
like the the best reviews I mean best
reviews in terms of the most useful and
interesting ones the like it most but
the the best reviews are often the ones
without scores which is very weird as a
game developer to like right because
obviously you're watching Metacritic on
launch day and you're paying attention
to all this
it's interesting that you often find the
better written reviews and the more
interesting ones all usually probably
because the others are written to
justify the school so you have to be
like probably what my school is going to
be also it does this it's like no one's
gonna really click on a review that's an
85 or an 87 but they're gonna click on
that 38 they're gonna click on that 65
and most people don't even do a 100 it's
it's the the problem is we want to see
the dirty what did you find terrible
about it when we won't even get will
save des training for a different
different podcast but the lowest s
training school 30 yeah I big crashed
the site they got so much traffic that's
like basically an independent site in
Australia you know the guy who runs the
site and it crashed because it got so
much traffic 38 there's no metrics for
that it's all as epictetus and marcus
aurelius at all his opinion all his
opinion that's all this nests but
sometimes for for people those opinions
are fascinating and compelling yeah i -
you're I have to I have to quote very
possibly my favorite film of all time
Troy since you said Hudson Hawk as much
as I wish I could say I'm Michael came
and scored film is my favorite of all
time alas no I don't know I I'm not
prepared to defend it truly as my
all-time but it's a it's definitely a
candidate for it which is ratatouille
and it's just to me it's the best film
made about passion but the actual review
that he writes at the end Peter
O'Toole's
voicing of Anton ego I think speaks to
the question I asked but also to Troy to
your point about like there's an in
there's a real incentive for negative
and I pulled up the quote to make sure I
got it right because I just I love it so
much where he says in many ways the work
of a critic is easy because we risk very
little
and yet enjoy a position over those who
offer up their work and their selves to
our judgement we thrive on negative
criticism which is fun to write and to
read but the bitter truth that we
critics face is that in the grand scheme
of things the average piece of junk is
probably more meaningful than our
criticism designating it so why create
like that is that is like it's that's
like every Aaron Sorkin script I'm going
to write a critic into my movie but he's
going to agree with me you know the fact
that he realizes that his real job in
this story is to defend the new to
defend the original and that that's that
actually can be quite a big risk it's
the flip side of what you said Ilana
about you know if something is extremely
hyped there's incentive to pour all this
love onto it but I would are you tell me
if this is true but it seems like the
opposite like in this quote is
absolutely the case like if if there's
something everybody's hating and the
kind of the bandwagon has spoken but you
think it's being you know it's been it's
something redeeming has been missed
or it's somehow great yeah so I've done
that too there's an obligation just
defended always but they still get mad
I'm still like I wrote this piece that I
repeatedly hunted on about how it's cold
now the EA program that unravel came out
of originals yes yeah originals was like
originals is actually really good
because aside from unravel actually they
retain the IP and make all the profits
so EA will basically cover their own
costs but not actually take any money
beyond that which is why a way out was
extremely profitable for right guy it's
like it's very good for Indies but even
writing that I said something positive
about EA so I Michelle and I just have
to die and that's like one of the most
difficult parts of it is that you have
to manage the fact that you can write
something and think that it's honest but
nobody won't remember it so they get mad
at you at the time but then when the
thing comes out and you were right
nobody's like you were right and I
didn't buy that because you said that or
I listened to you and I went in with
certain expectations they just [ __ ] on
you and then completely forget that it
ever happened all you do it the other
way around you just accused of being
paid off so the I don't think the
audience realizes how against honesty
they actually are but if I weren't being
honest my job would be completely
pointless why would I be doing it I
think the riskiest thing that that the
four of us can be to answer your
question
Austin is to do everything regardless of
how it will be received but knowing that
it will be received and to do so
honestly it's it's Ilana it's you
writing an article that says Andromeda
just as critically it's not gonna you
know objectively speaking it's it has
these flaws
Austin it's you writing a score that
doesn't do the one for five and sounds
what we really want kind of like a Hans
Zimmer thing it's you doing that and
Mike it's you basically doing every game
that you've ever made which is this is
the game that I can make and this is I
[Laughter]
think it's well structured I'm sure the
comments will reflect that I think it's
going really well very well for me I
have some pad thai that is Austin has
informed me it's getting cold and I am
ravenous with hunger we did not talk
about anything but Star Wars and now
criticism how bad the part one dude we
got we got des training to get into
we've got stadia we've got a whole bunch
of stuff to you yet Troy so I don't know
how far I am in that game I probably
need to play more before we talk it's I
think you have to play for 17 days
straight I think I come in around our
just get me through the first cutscene
though that's that's a little preview of
my opinion so far all right before
Troy's pet eye gets cold yes thank you
for tuning in episode one everyone will
be doing this
well it'll be live the last Friday of
every month basically this is this is a
format I don't want it to be very
scripted I don't want us to have to
follow anything strict but we'll just
talk
about the stuff that were either
thinking about or playing or watching in
any given month yeah I can leave a
comment just asking people what they
they want us to name it but I guess this
is a pilot so let's figure all that
stuff out it'll be great
why can't everyone find Ichi I think you
should be called I'm a wintry everywhere
doesn't violate the terms of their User
Agreement that they have to give it back
to me so I'm a dot wintry on Instagram
for the occasional posting their
Twitter's Troy Baker VA insta official
Troy Baker is the only place I'm ever
active obviously far too active full
name yeah all right
and you're on my youtube channel so that
will be in the description below I will
link out to everyone stuff we did it we
did absurd one help us find a name of
whatever the show is up and Adam maybe
will still talk about Sawa's next month
be that [ __ ] movies coming up
well and there's more Mandalorian
episodes so this is gonna do story roll
in with that so good man so I'll get
caught up I'll get caught up I promise